some people think having a busy calendar  shows how important they are not true  [Music]  whether you're a teacher or a leader or  a small business owner after you take  this class you will emerge a better  thinker better listener a better  analyzer of problems  in this class I teach you how did I  motivate an organization how did I set a  direction how did I make sure the  company stayed successful over multiple  years  you've got to understand how any  decision made at the top translates all  the way down to the front line and  that's what makes you an effective and  efficient leader  I'm indranui and this is Master Class  [Music]